(audience applauding)
- But y'all are in for
such a great hour.
Not only do we have an incredible lineup
of guests that I'm super excited
about because I love this franchise.
What? But we've also got puppies.
(puppies whining)
(audience cheering)
We got puppies. And it's incredible.
And it's-
Do you wanna come here?
- [Audience] Aw!
- That's right. It's National Puppy Day.
Snuggle up.
I already have two dogs.
This is so dangerous.
So we have a pen of some of the
cutest ones on set right now.
The best part is y'all, all
these little guys are up
for adoption through
our friends at Paw Works
and you're gonna want one.
They're so great.
It's actually fitting this
as National Puppy Day y'all
because we have the cast of John Wick
chapter four with us today.
I love the John Wick movies.
It's a wildly successful
franchise in which dogs
play an important role.
It's actually why all of
them started, is the dog.
The John Wick movies
have been so successful.
They led to multiple sequels
as well as video games,
comic books, a spinoff film,
and an upcoming TV show.
Am I gonna get this dog
and name it John Wick?
Maybe.
Many critics call this the best action
franchise ever made.
John Wick chapter four is in theaters now.
It's incredible.
If you like action, this is your movie.
And starting us off, please
welcome John Wick himself.
Keanu Reeves.
(upbeat music)
Happy National Puppy Day.
Do you like puppies?
- Happy puppy day.
- Oh my God. Look, they all came to you.
Is this the John Wick
effect? Do you do this?
- This is the John Wick effect.
- We might have to get the one.
- Yo, buddy. It's okay.
It's a puppy-pede.
- I think we need help.
I think we need help.
- Fellas. Fellas, fellas and misses.
Hang out for a second.
We're gonna hang out.
- We're gonna hang out.
- We're gonna be okay.
- We're gonna get you some love.
- This is called the
John Wick Effect people.
- We're gonna hang out.
We're just gonna chill out.
- We're just gonna chill out.
- We're gonna chill out. We'll be back.
- Maybe give the dogs some-
- Go hang out.
- So the first John Wick movie
started because of a dog.
And a dog plays a pretty
big role in, in the new one.
Like a huge one.
- Yes.
- Like one that you do
not want to piss off.
So I mean, John Wick, the movies kind of
keep a connection with dogs
and I, I know that the,
the connection was from your
late wife in the first movie.
So I love this common
theme that it came back in
like the fourth installment too.
Do you like it? Do you have a dog?
Did you have a dog growing up?
- I, I had dogs.
I had a dog growing up.
Jupiter.
- Oh, Jupiter.
- Was a English bull Mastiff.
And I was little and it was tall.
- That's adorable.
- Yeah. And he would like sit there.
I remember he would sit like this
and I would go inside
there and I'd like feed him
like cereal. Watch tv.
- That connection is so important.
I think I had dogs and animals growing up
and I think it teaches
you a certain amount
of selflessness and taking
care of something else
and thinking outside
yourself when you're a kid.
- Yeah. It's nothing like cleaning up dog-
- Dog poop.
- That was my job. So I was just like,
I love my dog.
And then yeah. Feed it.
Yep. And the companionship and yeah.
And just I, you know,
oftentimes you spend time with
you know, your dog or your pet
and stuff when you're alone.
- Yeah.
- You know, so it's kind of
a nice companionship going
for walks while you're
thinking and feeling.
- Yeah.
- You got a hound there.
You know, you can play.
- I love this whole setup you just set up.
I wanna go on a walk
with my dogs right now.
I also found this interesting though.
So did you know that scientists recently
named a molecule after you?
- I've heard that a couple of times.
- I think you made it.
When you get a molecule named-
when scientists are like you're rad enough
to name a molecule after- just saying.
- I don't know.
I, I hope that there's, you
know, that it's a good molecule.
I hope that it's-
- I think it's like a molecule.
It might eat like all the other bacteria
like annihilates thing.
So I think it should have
been called John Wick.
- Yeah, right. Yeah.
- Because it's Keanu Mycin
I think is what it's called.
Cause it's, it's, it's deadly.
Yeah. Just saying.
- But healthy.
- Well it depends on what the
bacteria it's eating, but yes.
- Yeah. Hopefully. I know
that's kind of crazy.
- I don't have a molecule named after me.
- That's surreal. But I don't know. Yeah.
- I think it's cool.
- It is funny.
- So wait, where, where does that rank
having a molecule named after you and
like, I don't know, awards.
Where does this rank in your life?
- Really different.
- What a politically correct answer.
Both are cool but different.
- Yes. They can't compete.
Apples and oranges.
So what kind of science
and tech are you into?
Are you into like stuff like that?
- Science and tech?
Yeah, yeah.
I mean I think, I don't, I
don't know anything but I like-
- I'm interested in it.
No, I'm not like adept in everything
but I love learning better,
watching documentaries
and stuff like that.
- Yeah. Astrophysics.
- Did you see Fantastic Fungi on Netflix?
- No. No.
- You're welcome.
- Okay.
- It's super good.
- No, but also seen some of
the James Webb telescope.
- Yes.
- Some of the information
that's coming back from there.
And the new discoveries.
- I think that's so interesting.
- Yeah. Get some math going.
- Have other people do it
and then you get to just
the knowledge of it.
- No, you just sit back, right.
- I don't do math. Yeah.
- Thank you for figuring this out.
- Right. What is, there's
something in there like yeah
I can't do it, but I really enjoy it.
I think that's probably most things.
- People's brains work
differently. That's what I say.
So we recently had actually
the mathematician Hannah Fry
here. It, she just shared
some mind blowing stuff.
I thought it was so cool and interesting.
I want to go have lunch with her.
But it was about artificial intelligence.
So what are your thoughts on AI?
Cause it's already here
obviously our phones were,
we already have AI very present.
- Artificial Intelligence.
- Yes. Like I'm just saying
like self-driving cars, like all that.
What's your-
- That's machine learning.
- Okay.
That's tasks.
Is that quite intelligence?
- What do you consider? Okay
well how- where are you?
- I mean, there's a bridge, right?
Like the uncanny valley.
What's real, not real.
What's really intelligence?
What's the-
- Yeah.
- What's the, how are
we thinking about that?
But that being said,
yes, it's, it's all around us
and it's coming for a
job near you, anyway.
- Yeah.
I know. That's so true. That's so true.
We are back with Keanu Reeves.
Give it up everybody.
(audience cheers)
That was a look at his new movie
John Wick Chapter Four.
It's in theaters now.
So this is your fourth
time playing John Wick.
So how do you like, do you
go through like intense
like training for this all over again?
Because these fight
fighting sequences are,
they're intense.
- Yeah, they're, they're intense.
- Especially this movie.
- Yeah. We went crazy.
- Like how do you get
prepared for a role like that?
Like that?
- Love.
- Yeah. Okay.
- Yeah, it's love. You have to have love.
Yeah. So many questions there.
Yes. I mean I love the
role, I love preparing,
I love training and then going
from training into the flow.
There's so much cooperation.
Teaching and then going
into the action of it.
And then for me
just what's dramatically
the story being told.
And what I mean by that is, you know
John Wicks fighting for his life.
- Yeah.
- You know, and he kind
of gets knocked down.
He gets hit by cars, he
jumps out of windows,
he gets shot off of buildings,
but he keeps coming back.
He keeps trying.
- Yeah.
- He keeps fighting for his freedom.
- Which I think is a nice metaphor.
Like watching, like I, I
literally had a rough day
like this is me going
deep on this, but like
I had a rough day and then I
got home and I was like, oh
I get to watch this.
It's the coolest thing about
this job too, is you get to
watch stuff before it
comes out and you, you know
before you interview people and you know
what you're talking about.
Anyway, I got- no, I love it.
And, and so I, I had a rough
day and then I watched it
and it was like kind
of therapeutic to watch
cause you're like, yeah, he keeps going.
I know. Me too.
But you know, you sometimes I feel like
in life we do feel like we
just keep getting knocked down
knocked down, knocked
down and you get back up.
I like the metaphor of that.
- Yeah, for sure.
And I, I, that's something that I really
respond to as well.
His will. His determination.
And you know, in, in
chapter four we have a lot
of new characters and, you
know, themes of friendship,
brotherhood, family, father, daughter,
consequences and open
up the John Wick world
and there's some crazy action sequences,
but there's lots of heart-
- It's like true friendship.
- Go to the movies, eat some
popcorn, see it on screen.
- No, I'm lucky.
- That's what we tried.
- I am lucky, like with my set at home
cause it's like, you wanna
see this in like a theater
like vibe, like you
wanna, it's, it's intense.
The sound, the feel.
- You know, that was definitely something
that we were trying to do, so.
- Yeah. Well done.
- I, I can say on behalf of the director
and the cast and-
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
And we're glad that you liked the film
and that you, that these
themes resonated with you.
- It is so, it is, it's so great.
You did a great job, just then.
That was nice.